oh I have missed you guys so much homies
how are ya how you live and how you
feeling here's a deal we have a very
nice and long interview with super
trainer
travell Gaines this guy has trained se
Quan he trains Todd Gurley he's trained
Jimmy Butler Antonio Brown he shares
story after story
Nikhil Harry he's telling me right now
Patriots fans should be really excited
really good conversation that's coming
up but I haven't had a chance to do an
intro in a while and I had to talk to
you guys it is the lef koe man and the
other thing that I forgot is last week I
was supposed to play a freestyle over
the new intro and I forgot to play it so
at the very end you're gonna hear at the
end of the travel games interview the
music will sign off
don't be done because you've got to hear
the Freestyle cuz it's that good first
thing I need to talk about though is 33%
guys tides are starting to change I
don't know if you guys are starting to
feel it I hope you see it right now but
we're reaching a point where what we do
on this show is starting to grow and
it's really because of you guys think
about what happened the last two weeks
Colet CEO semele comes on speaks the
truth you guys hit up colette she were
retweeting it talking about how great it
is there were two podcasts that came out
last week that were just talking about
this podcast we're moving and we're
shaking and we're moving then Ted Ginn
comes on and says I can race anybody
$10,000 guys we were the number two
trending topic on Apple news hour dude
Matthew bowling white lightning high
school kids says bet challenge I mean we
created media inception there was an
article that said local high school
track star response to Pro Football Talk
tweet
which was about the left ghost show so I
just want you guys to know that when you
see something from this show spread it's
because of you guys
because you're the 33% that taken over
the top I wanted to say thank you to you
guys because it's [ __ ] awesome and
we're doing great [ __ ] and do not think
that Ted Ginn will not run this race as
soon as this thing started blowing up he
texts him and he goes bro you did it lol
I'm just letting you guys know that if
you see anyone try to take ownership of
this we need to let them know to stand
down this is a left go show thing this
is a bleacher report thing if Ted Gaines
racing were doing it don't let any other
company we've organised a race no you
didn't we need to fight them tooth and
nail 33% I mean shoot one of my favorite
podcast host and comedian Theo von said
he front the $10,000 for the kid I want
to get Theo von involved we're gonna
make this an event I'm very excited
about it the other thing I'm really
excited about I was in Vegas and I did
something let's see if I can find it
here it is this is a betting slip
I bet the Eagles to win the Superbowl
I'm just putting it out there I got the
Eagles at twenty to one which I always
look for teams anywhere between 16 and
1/2 22 to 1
Eagles were right there feeling good
Chris long retired didn't feel great
about that dude only goes to Super Bowls
but I put 20 on it I could win 400 I
just wanted to share that with you so if
the Eagles do win you'll know the dude
that bet them on May 15th to win a
little bit of that cash one last thing I
want to say before we get into this
interview with travell Gaines
I am about to start eating healthy but I
have one promise to you I am NOT gonna
talk about eating healthy
however when we've talked about doing
healthy stuff in the past I remember we
got a few y'all y'all lost like 20 30
pounds and you got my DMS
I kind of want to make this a thing
because you guys ride with me I write
you you support me I support you we're
gonna do 33 days of eating like a homie
so today is day 1 I'm gonna do 34 cuz I
gotta pull up that extra 1% so you guys
start if you're if you're listening and
you want to you got to do it
Tuesday and we'll go 33 days I'll go 34
I'll start Monday you start Tuesday
that's how much I care but you'll hear
travell when I bring this up to him he
has a very special offer that the person
that does the best we're gonna get you
out to California and train with this
dude he what he's the one that offered
it so you'll hear it but I just thought
if I'm about to eat healthy I need to
lose some weight
imma go through some transition do my
thing you know what I mean get nice if
you want to do it too great but I
promise that I'm not gonna sit here and
be like man I really wanted to meet some
itzá I'm not I'm not doing that whole
thing so if you want to join the journey
with me great if you want to slide to my
DMS and send pictures or give me notes
and you want them to be shared I'm happy
to repost them let's do this success
together y'all the [ __ ] I'm trying to be
as cool as y'all so let's get to travell
gains as he breaks down everything from
what it's like to Train Todd Gurley and
sake one at the same time to the
strongest most expensive explosive
players have recovered to who are the
best athletes in the NFL from a workout
person perspective let's get to the man
TG travel gains right here on the left
coast show
[Music]
Jim how you feeling how you livin how
you doing
we got travell gains in the building how
you feeling
great yeah right don't get [ __ ] quiet
on me now never this man walked into the
building with so much energy I want that
energy there I want all of it yeah
travell Gaines you run athletic games
nutrition yes you are what would your
fish how do you introduce yourself to
people
I'm just the founder of athletic gains
you know a company where we put together
sports performance training programs for
athletes from physical therapy strength
training speed training nutrition sure
everything and you've been doing this
for a long time 15 years now and you've
seen you've you've probably trained guys
that were rookies that went into the
league and then I've already retired
correct so you've seen the process
everything I'm what I have so many
questions because I did this thing last
year called Lefko PR yeah where I
noticed there's this trend of athletes
working on the offseason throw on some
music on it and then everyone getting
height - holy crap look at se Kwang's
workout oh man oh Dells insane and so
now you trainers are becoming stars
right like have you noticed that change
as well
right you know what's funny I talk about
this all the time I'm in a weird space
where I'm kind of old school but this is
new generation so when I first started
training there these older trained odor
trainers are trainers from the
background and now new it nowadays with
all this Instagram stuff like the
trainers all about the trainers I mean
you have you know the speed demon and
yeah you know the footwork doctor
there's a guy there's got new orleans
it's about balance yeah yeah yeah and so
it's it's tough because I've still done
a good job of having that balance where
I don't post a lot of stuff but we make
it all about our athletes like if you
own the athletic gains Instagram page
I'm barely on it yeah my my I was gonna
say like if you need help with the IG
payroll I got you you don't want to know
you think it's actually been a benefit
posting correct correct because I think
when you make it all about the athletes
they appreciate that you know and how
they said that to you yeah all the time
really all the time I mean if people say
all the time you should have a million
followers because if people you know if
I post a hundred percent or nine percent
of stuff I did and people think where I
had a cool life but just don't I don't
think it's that interesting you know
driving down the street and yeah wheels
up but I'm not talking about that I'm
talking more about like if you got a
big-name athlete in there pushing some
weight or a sled or something like that
I mean that that will be big you said
well it's up to them though Adam that's
true it's up to them all right we're
gonna have a nice long conversation but
I think the homies the listeners the 33%
they like a different perspective on
what we do but I want to know your path
you grew up in New Orleans I had to what
age I live there in 12 freshman high
school and then from there where'd you
go the most of the Bay Area alright
before we do that what is it what do I
need to know about people from New
Orleans for the rest of my life because
you came in here talking [ __ ] about me
being from Philly 100% you're a piece of
[ __ ] yeah you are what about New Orleans
how did that kind of define you a little
bit take from New Orleans a lot it
taught me my humility it taught me my
humbleness it taught me my work ethic
you know and I watched my parents and my
family members get up and work every
single day you know for 6 a.m. to 6 p.m.
basic stuff janitors cook you know
nothing just blue-collar pizza but just
to appreciate everything that that you
have it's funny your life gives you and
so it was it's really big for me every
day to take advantage of every
opportunity you have and not take
anybody for granted anything for granted
so people appreciate that and that's
what New Orleans has taught me and then
you go to De La Salle High School like
the high school football powerhouse
never lost you didn't lose when you were
there never lost who else was on the
squad DJ Williams Atari Callen
Matt Gutierrez DJ Williams was my secret
weapon and Madden right on that Denver
Broncos defense yeah yeah like a 90
speed or something like that crazy part
about it he was the same size in high
school as he was in the NFL Wow so that
was like was that your first taste of an
NFL level athlete
I mean not necessarily because everybody
was the same there you know Nemean like
everybody worked hard everybody you know
everybody was strong everybody was
bigger it was fast though he was the
normal guy yeah so you go to de LaSalle
and then did you draft it and Major
League Baseball on a high school or
college out of high school by the
Montreal Expos alright so you're playing
baseball De La Salle - yeah how nasty
were you I was okay I mean I can't okay
you weren't [ __ ] 11th round yeah yeah
I think it was a combination of what you
got to understand Adam is I never really
thought I was that good in anything
mmm just like today I still don't think
I'm the greatest trainer in the world I
don't because once you start believing
you're better I mean you really are you
stop working and once you stop working
you stop getting better and so I've
never gotten caught up with who I'm
training or what I've done or my stats
or whatever is you're just a guy on the
team and just you know what was your
position and baseman shortstop day yeah
who'd you look up to Derek Jeter and
Barry Bonds what about football football
I love Randall Cunningham love Randall
Cunningham so you can root for ribbon
cutting in but hey Phil enough
absolutely he was a Minnesota Viking
member that so yeah who else other than
Randall though i love Randall I love
Marshall folk well my favorite players
of all times we know being friends as he
got older she lived in Calabasas as well
dude isn't it don't when you grow up
rooting for somebody and then can like
be friends with them like I'm starting
to experience that now we're like I'm
starting to meet guys and and you
established that's it's interesting for
my job because sometimes I want to [ __ ]
on everybody and then once I meet
somebody I'll never [ __ ] on them yeah
yeah but it's it's a have you met
Randall before oh yeah yeah I've met
Brandon have a have his phone number
everything and a lot of interactions
with a mine in Las Vegas
the original Mike Vick yeah and then did
you know you want to go on a like
personal like not personal training but
like weight training and performance no
no the funny part about it I actually
wanted to be a high school principal I
want to be a high school principal and
eventually become a high school
superintendent so I want to make change
in urban communities you know what I
mean and so my college strength coach
got a job at the University of Louisiana
Monroe and he was
hey man I think he would be a great
strength coach you from Louisiana move
back here and I was like nah man I'm
good off that and he talked me into it
and while I were you
so he's he thought you'd be a good
strength coach were you always the guy
in the gym always even even high school
yeah so you go to De La Salle known for
being this like world-renowned high
school athletic campus
did you try and stunt on everybody the
first day no no ha so what made you so
special though in the weight room I just
for me I had a low self-esteem when I
was a kid you know I had low self-esteem
just because I was a poor kid you know
Nemean and so by going and transforming
my body in the weights I saw like
instant growth because I was from the
skinny kid to being pretty jacked and so
I just saw results I stuck with it
mm-hmm how much were we mention oh and
come out of high school I think I was
doing 335 or 340 5 and then out of
college 455 my senior and then your
all-time high 455 and that's where it's
tough yeah it's not squat
I think it's quite a 705 in my senior
year of college I always think I could
squat like 700 pound I think you could
probably squat maybe 185 when I walked
in did you size me up I mean I thought
it'd you know you like you had a very
good host body like you don't play any
sports or anything like that you could
host the hell out of some show or you
could text really fast even or I am and
I said this before this show that I am
so my listeners are the 33%
I've given part of the show to them and
I've decided that it's time to kick in a
health gear and so it's not a challenge
they can get down with it or not we're
doing 33 days I like eating like a homey
just eating healthy and I'm not gonna
put pressure on them and if they want to
put pressure on me that's cool cuz I
probably need it too but we gonna we're
gonna get this right for the month of
May into June I tell you what I'm gonna
join in with you in Oslo any one of the
listeners okay who performed the best
they send them in your results yeah
cinema le for a week come train with
pros at F little games
damn yeah I was not planning on bringing
this up now we got some real [ __ ] yeah
percent this is a thing now we've gotten
notes in the past about people because
we used to profess beans not beef like
eat eat beans already for protein all
that to be healthy right I'm sweating
now now I really got to do it let's
repeal is involved yeah so you go to
Louisiana Monroe
mmm-hmm and what was like being a
strength coach right away fell in love
with it I fell in love with the grind I
fell in love with the results because
you got to understand the strength coach
is the only coach who can work with the
athletes all year round
you know because no minimum time right
yeah correct correct and so you're able
to directly affect and change how they
get better the next season so an athlete
would come to you and say you know what
I wasn't that fast this year okay we're
gonna speed
I wasn't that strong right hip
flexibility wasn't there so you design
and I work on my bulrush yeah exactly
exactly so and then was there a guy like
was there a kid early on that kind of
took to it well or was it like all them
are like man I'm seeing results right
now yeah I think it was more so I was
able to connect with them on a personal
level because if things are similar age
to them to it here you know I was like
23 or 24 but the thing about being a
performance trainer is you have to
figure out what motivates every single
person you come across mmm so
everybody's motivated by different stuff
some people want to be the best ever
play some people just want to start some
people's want to get a new contract
right somebody's want to make a team so
whatever that is you have to figure that
out and push them some people you yell
at them some people you got to be quiet
with yous got to figure out how to I'm
sure you don't just say what motivates
you how do you figure that out what's
the process that you've used to realize
that when you make it about the athlete
at your training they eventually will
will confining you and tell and tell you
what's important to them mm-hmm you know
and it like like you'll what be sitting
there after a workout and then someone
it just kind of falls out of their mouth
like well sometimes durn you know
because you hear you know different
people getting psyched up or just
talking to themselves our facetiming or
who they have on their phone or just
different things so you're paying
attention all that got you because
someone will come out there and they'll
just be like FaceTime on their mommy
like I'm just trying to be the best of
all time 100 in your head you go
yeah and then so what do you do once you
figure that out figure how to motivate
them figure how to bring that person up
figure out how to not to bring that
person up figuring out just when they
are at their weakest moments is sandy
for things like for example had Randall
Cobb this offseason and I think rental
Cobbs a phenomenal player and he worked
so hard and I would constantly remind
Randall that people say he you're done
your watch and it would just drive him
to do more and do some more sets and now
he's out in Dallas he's doing very well
and so he was the guy that got fed by
doubters yeah he needed a little chip on
his shoulder 100% well how did you
realize that easy by just one thing and
kind of enraged him what was this and he
was washed like bringing up oh they're
not listen use the top five free agent Y
receiver so did you just kind of throw
that out there to see how he'd react and
then what about him you did you go
that's it yep what does he do he just
again he started to want to do more
sense when do more reps wanted to do
more pile box jumps just one more yeah
and so you're really looking also for
what's gonna cause them to do more one
hundred percent
mm - dig deep so I oh I would assume
that a chip on the shoulder is the
easiest way to motivate what I'm sayin
you ain't got it everyone's saying you
don't got it all
what is the opposite of that like some
people need to be built up a lot I think
there's some people like Ryan Mathews
the foreign player short for the San
Diego Chargers Chargers Eagles Fresno
State yeah a Fresno State
fun fact only player ever to lead high
school football in Russia in college
football Russian like the whole College
for 4,000 yards rushing in high school
and Chancellor's rushing his junior year
of college man so but Ryan is a guy who
you have to constantly give him positive
feedback just that's just what it is you
know not saying that he was mentally
weak cuz he's a very tough kid but just
constantly wanted positive feedback like
what kind of stuff I just call just
cause he told him he's great you're
doing good
I think you would see him do more
because of that yeah interest and now
Jimmy Butler on the other hand yeah that
guy right there man you know you have to
tell him the ain't [ __ ] every day and he
wants to hear it you know cuz he just
wants to that didn't taste a man him
being draft at the end of the first
round was such a benefit for him oh yeah
motivation Aaron he's one of the most
highly
motivated people very men in my life
there would be times will you be driving
to the arena I was like ma'am over 50
tonight hike all right Jamie whatever 50
seriously because he spoke it into
existence that dude is so prepared and
the way he pushed himself the way he
believes himself and the way he wills
himself there's nothing like it some
teams gonna be in for a treat this
Aussie it's better be the [ __ ] Sixers
bro I'm gonna tell you like this oh god
you're gonna hurt my feelings no no no
I'm gonna tell you like this I can't
speak on - I don't know what Jimmy's
gonna do I don't know Jimmy knows what
he's gonna do but I think whatever team
gets him they are in for a treat you
know we saw it this postseason that he
was the one taking all the big shots and
making another big place he's valuable
in the Philly smart they'll run it back
I hope so I think I think you just cut
yourself off though you were about to
make a prediction and then you gave all
these qualifiers so what were you gonna
say where do you think he ends up
Clippers I think he ends up I think of
who if I had to guess I would probably
say - Clippers it makes sense to me he's
an LA guy right he loves Allah and then
like after what the Clippers did this
offseason are in this postseason like
that was really impressive but I can
definitely see him going back to Philly
I would love that
yeah I think a lot of people love that
you you took shots at at Philly to me
earlier and then said it was tough for
me because I'm a Tom Brady fan diehard
from Bert like like tell me about it my
Tom everybody knows it I ignore
everybody with it I mean Jimmy we have a
group chat with Jimmy al qasas him Tom
Brady pitchers I didn't put your a real
big fan o fanatical
but everybody knows it fanatical you
know I think with with Tom just the way
he works in the way he's filled by
doubters and just the way he just bucks
up the boys and just you're saying
create stories great stories man create
stories I think you notice the funniest
think about Tom Tom Brady actually
thought from a motivational stand put he
would be cut after winning the MVP in a
Super Bowl and that was just fuel
through the whole offseason because he
saw Matt Cassel the year before just
stepped right in and play well then he
also in return
had taken blitzes job so in his mind
he's expendable so he has to keep
working keep working keep it's crazy so
when you hear guys like him or like a
Russell Wilson and and their everyday
gotta get a little bit better and and
the rest of the the public and media
it's like we're tired of these quotes
you're going that's the mindset you have
to have though it's so it's so a typical
of the rest of us we're like tell us
something real and you're like no stay
make the big thing the big thing you
know something to Adam I'm gonna tell
you something that mentality applies not
only to sports but in business so you
meet some of the best businessmen
they're the exact same way they're the
exact same way you know they're a serial
killers dream they're very disciplined
they go to bed early they wake up early
they work out and they're so motivated
by what they can do so a lot of times
that's why a lot of athletes do very
well in business and also a lot of
efforts are good speakers oh look at
Kobe like that dude wasn't gonna fail
yeah ever absolutely you're at louisia
Monro yeah then you go to LSU yeah and I
don't know who this guy is but it seems
like it's an important deal Gale hatch
yeah so can you explain to everybody
what his role is in this world of yours
Gale hatch is Gale hatch and Tommy
Moffett are probably the two most
important influential people in my
training life I learned how to control
the room control environment and to
train in a group I said in from Tommy
Moffett
I learned the technical aspects of
training and Pence into detail from Gil
hatch and Gill hatch he was what the
coach of the u.s. Olympic team yeah and
he was based in Baton Rouge and what
happened was I first got the job at LSU
coach Moffitt said hey go spend a couple
days with coach hatch so what I started
to do was every day when I got off of
work at three four o'clock I would say
with Coach has to twelve o'clock one
o'clock in the morning just learn from
him most times who wake me up cuz he'll
be sitting there talking you know that's
enough for the day home but I make for
3045 minute drive every day across town
and just learn everything from you've
got like a one-year intensive course of
just following a guy that was the USA
coach and you're not gonna get that job
unless you're technically perfect
and just kind of seen the way he moves
right how much of his stuff did you
steal just like all of it mm training is
nothing but let me tell you something
training is nothing but stealing no one
created none of these movements or
exercises just so you know what people
do is they see what they like and they
put their spin on it and they pair it
with different things but I've stole
every single exercise that your life
I've done from somebody hmm so you know
but my philosophy comes from yo Hatchin
time I feel like people are so
protective and like they're so defensive
of their strategy though we're people
because you got to think about it
training is a service-oriented business
you seen I'm saying so it's not like a
quantitative thing but you can say and
he goes these numbers or that numbers
it's it's a service-oriented business so
you have to even have the results or you
have to talk mess about somebody to
tears about somebody to get clients
right and so my thing has been just
looking my client list that's just kind
of being like because the true thing is
is it seems very opposite of a trainer
to go let me get a quick fix right
because every trainer I've ever had has
told me there's no [ __ ] quick fixes
never and yet so if talking shits gonna
get you attention if anyone's gonna know
that this isn't good for the long game
it's a trainer right right absolutely
then you go to you started performance
games yeah in 2007 in Seattle yeah why
were you in Seattle a long story but I
had definitely a woman ya know my first
few athletes Marcus Trufant is due for a
millionnaire Coleman and then I had
Brandon Roy mm-hmm and oh so you had
like the young faces of the Seattle
secondary and then like everybody loved
Brandon Roy man one of the greatest
that's a crazy story he's the ultimate
what could have been story in the NBA so
I'm living in Seattle 2007 I didn't have
a car and I'm going and training these
guys all around town matter of fact
Brennan trained in Mercer Island and
every day after workouts you know the
guys are kind of leave and I'll be the
last one leaves and when they they're
like where's your car at I don't want to
tell them I'd have a car and so the very
next day Jamal Crawford and Brennan
I got me a Dodge Charger it was so nice
- how long have you been working out
with them before that Oh months Wow yeah
yeah I don't want to tell anybody my
issues are my problems though what's so
interesting about that is it just takes
me to what you were saying before about
New Orleans yeah
about being self-conscious about that
stuff and I'm sure you had it for a long
time yeah I'm sure you huh I'm sure you
did extra workouts just to avoid that
conversation you can't be taking the
[ __ ] bus yeah
damn was it scary when they asked no I
just it was just kind of like whatever
you know and so but there were such
great guys yeah like you're not still
praise Brandon Roy to this day like he's
one of the greatest people I've ever
been around and now he's like a big-time
coach big-time coach man I'm so happy
for him he's the man well you were
saying before too that you go this is my
client list yeah who would you say was
the first client that gave you instant
validation to everybody else
Brandon Bruin Reggie Bush Reggie Bush
yeah what year was that 2001 eight seven
eight
so he's is he in the league or is that
you turning his rookie you know he was
in his second year so with the Saints
and how did you guys get mad like how
that introduction happened yeah just
kind of met him and started training him
and you know but I feel like you like
that that process of meeting and then
becoming a trainer that's like a very
like what was your sales pace like how
did you play it off did you like is it
like dating the the funny part about it
I never had a sales pitch I think it's a
connection thing and at that time people
understand how famous Reggie Bush was at
that time like I'm doing betting
push-ups with Kim Kardashian on just a
cover of People magazine he's magazine
he was famous famous like grown men was
he Reggie Bush walking the street and
faint yeah so just to get in with him
was tough sure but it's also treating
them like a human being
the last thing he want to be treated
like was Reggie Bush and you know I
think I was able to do that and that's
what it started the relationship and he
was he was the man so how much did [ __ ]
change like like what were the things
that changed when you started treat
training Reggie Bush like what were the
phone calls like what how did people
talk to you well the funny part is in
LeSean McCoy would not admit this
hope you listen to Sean he would not
admit this to this day but LeSean McCoy
was a die-hard Reggie Bush fan he stole
his swag the stock nuts
yep it's running style everything about
him the he had seven where's he from
Harrisburg seven-one-seven right he had
here because Reggie Bush had like six oh
nine six one exactly and he would not
admit it to this day so I got LeSean
McCoy because of I trained Reggie Bush
and then that started my whole running
back kind of cycle tree that I've had
and so
leshawna to this day still won't admit
it to me we go back and forth on
Instagram he stole Reggie Bush's whole
swagger but LaShawn reject this but but
but LeSean McCoy is what Reggie Bush
should have been mmm
offensive coordinators are a son of a
[ __ ] mm-hmm coaching is tough but in
back to this though like was there ever
a time where you were like like when did
you go this is gonna be my [ __ ] when did
that first happened because you said you
weren't sure you're gonna do like was it
Louisiana Monroe LSU like when did you
go this is it I think was even then
you're still a schools yeah no well I
think when I bought a one-way ticket in
2008 and moved to LA that's such a
trainer move for a lot of one-way ticket
there's no other way to do this come to
LA move to LA bought a one-way ticket
paid for an extended stay for 30 days
had no money actually had negative
seventeen dollars in my bank account
eight muscle milks every day I know I
had money coming so I was training
athletes yeah those first 30 days are
rough you know is you know looking at it
like Marshawn Lynch was down there
training with me yeah you wanna go to
dinner yes I do but that's when I was
all in when I was like hey man and at
that point it's just the kind of the
belief he can do it and then you know
when you have Marshawn Lynch and LeSean
McCoy and Ryan Mathews and Reggie Bush
and you kiss Colston and you have all
these athletes it starts to pile up but
you're not thinking about it cuz this
becomes your life right and so that's
been my life every single day for 15
years how did you figure out how to
charge people
in the beginning I did it for free and I
let people to pay me whatever and you
know hence the negative seventeen
dollars in debate yeah yeah but I think
after a while it really where my career
really took off was when I went over to
athletes performance now EXO's and I
think being there they're like the
biggest draft calm and prep thing ever
and I was deeply involved in that and
overseen that process for years you know
and working with the people there and
they are such a buttoned-up I mean I
can't praise him enough
you know when I hear a kid wants to go
they're like great idea you know I mean
they're it's such a buttoned up rail oil
machine I was talking to Josh Allen he
got attracted by the Jaguars and he was
like yeah me and Montez sweat man we
were trying to work out but he went to
the X hosting Texas I went to the exos
in Florida I was like five of them damn
I didn't realize and and what's cool is
these guys is they get ready for the
combine they kind of picked their
workout groups and they they they kind
of can challenge themselves what
motivated Marshawn Lynch what motivated
Marshawn Lynch besides been the funniest
person in the world his family in
Oakland he knew kind of like how damn
Lillard is he knew that that he was
Oakland Marshawn Lynch's is Oakland as
they come and I think just representing
be in the face of Oakland California
that's the representing him and his
family hmm you know he's serious about
his family in the family first stuff and
so how would you use that to motivate
him I mean from our shot it was more
Saudis getting him going I'm gonna tell
you something when more funny story two
thousand eight or nine Marshawn Lynch
was suspended for the first four games
of the season
and I had to go live in Buffalo Hamburg
New York to be very specific yeah and
stayed with him to work him out and get
ready for those friends Adam every day
it was first of all he had pit bulls
live in house with him which I thought
was crazy yeah and he had every day was
just a group of dudes with dreads and
goatee from Oakland there man and it was
it was crazy but Marshawn felt
comfortable and he provided them I think
with an opportunity and I hope and sure
he's just such a great guy did he ever
leave the house yeah he kind of brought
like he made like a house of oak karenge
a middle area like western New York
he brought the town to him
New York you know in a good hang I mean
he was a wild boy man yeah I loved him
for it
I love where he's him he's him no matter
what was a story where you were like wow
like Marshawn is is a hundred percent
himself just everyday that's every
single day he is who he is he says what
he wants to say he dresses how he wants
to dress he talks to people how he wants
to talk to people he doesn't switch up
for anybody and he's just a real dude
and he's a great guy he's unbleached oh
I will tell you that really he's cheap
that story about he has his 50 he
probably has marched on which probably
has his third grade lunch money that's
how cheap he is
that's incredible yeah so he was were
you man he's just he's like one of the
all-time characters in the NFL Marshawn
Lynch and I think so many people want to
get close to him like here he was going
I'm just here so I won't get fined and
all that and it drew more people to him
like he was pushing people away but it
only drew us more into him right
fascinating guy yeah yeah
I really would say stuff like people
coming to him and say hey marce now I
can have a picture other graphics I can
have your picture your autograph he just
wanted to be normal
mm he really liked to say that but
Marshawn Lynch truly just wanted to be a
normal person mmm that's why he hung on
Oakland say about you to normal so then
you you get involved with exos it starts
growing and then you I guess decided
it's time for me to do my own thing yeah
who was how big was the client list that
you felt confident or was there a like
certain people you're like I got this
now she had some funding how did that
happen no I think it was it was a
combination of both it was a combination
of you know when I was at EXO's I think
we ended up with the last year we had
like 16 first-round picks half the first
round and I think we had like a hundred
kids drafted I don't remember the name
but it got to the point was like now
what now you have to make your goals so
unrealistic it's now what and so then
you became a point with was can I do
this on my own
and I didn't have a lot of confident and
I can do it on my own but um enough yeah
fleets you know I had a Donald Penn Ryan
Clady Sean Goldston LeSean McCoy
good mix of different positions yes yeah
the Lamarr Houston Bobby Wagner had a
lot of really good athletes at that time
they were training with me and decided
to go for it and end up working out man
all right so you you tell your clients
when you're trying to get clients look
at my client list as there is there an
athlete that you haven't worked out with
yet that we can put it out into the
energy and get them in the gym athlete
other than Tom Brady because I don't
think he's gonna leave his house I think
a guy most of them yeah yeah
have you ever pushed a player too hard
that's a great question I would say yes
but it was for his own benefit more so I
pushed him through their threshold hmm
never like pushed somebody where they
got injured so something I'm very proud
of
I've never had an athlete get injured
with me while training and I wear guys
out hard so you know definitely a lot of
technical standpoint and on a scientific
standpoint I've never had like a
hamstring tear or Oh me I would I would
never had it crap never had it but these
guys they come in and so you've seen
like top NFL athletes look at you and go
this is too hard
correct Wow yeah there's not a lot of
people that get that experience does
that that juice you up a little bit no
no because this is I'm there for them
you know so for me it's like okay what I
planned on doing with him today was or
her was a little too much let me dial it
back let me push him by dial it back and
so that constant feed it's tricky for
every guy she got a guy like Antonio
Brown who man Antonio I'm in the first
time I met Antonio he walks into the gym
wearing a military-issued 50 pound
weighted vest and he's walking he got
out the car you have the car he's
walking around LA now believe he had
some bags he just went to like the young
and reckless store some like Tonio like
were you walking around town he's like
yeah man like he was walking around town
with a weighted vest on and for
performance I don't know what it was for
but he was walking around so you see
that what was your first thought this
guy's crazy but I
heard about his work ethic and you know
not all about him I have a good
relationship with his agent Drew
Rosenhaus and so I knew who he was
yeah how he was and we met and we
clicked so he takes the vest off and
what he should know sir absolutely not
he starts the workout wearing a 50-pound
weight events and you're probably in
your head going does he know the workout
that he's about to get right this is
unnecessary for him to wear a 50-pound
weighted vest what did he show you
he showed me just how tough he is
mentally vet guy is sheer will every
that guy he shear built on his desire to
be better I've never seen someone
workout like Antonio Brown you've worked
out with hundreds of the best athletes
and Antonio Browns the most motivated no
I tied between Antonio Brown and
probably Jimmy brother Wow yeah but
Antonio Browns will to be better is
higher than anybody I've ever seen in my
life so when you see all the stories
about ego and about you know all that
like what's your cuz this was a very
tumultuous offseason for Antonio Brown
what was your take is someone that's
trained the guy well first of all it's
been tough for me to watch because I've
never ever seen that side of Antonio
mm-hmm he's always been super respectful
just a great guy I've never seen a bad
side of him I've never heard him talk
bad about being Roethlisberger I never
heard him talk about about juji I never
heard him talk bad about anybody so you
were like legit shocked when all that
started sailing 100% like how would you
explain that to people
I mean people ask me all the time you
know but I thought it was out of
character of him
I think Antonio is an emotional guy but
emotional in a good way cuz he's
passionate about the game yeah but I was
shocked when I saw it but at the end the
day like that's my guy I'll ride or die
for Antonio Brown you know what I think
the Raiders got a they got a great asset
because he is he's human you to three
games by himself unfortunate readers
might only win two or three games but
Antonio might win them his we had Trent
Brown in here and he said you know I'm
gonna do my first workout of the day and
Antonio's already on his third
absolutely all Antonio does is work out
and he's such that what gets mixed
through all this stuff what people fail
to realize Antonio Brown is a phenomenal
father he takes his kids with him
everywhere he's active
their lives he goes to their sporting
events I mean this Duke is a great guy
yeah and again to see people kind of you
know you could take it for what is worth
what you know to be what he said was it
bad I don't know probably but for me
nothing that he said bothered me because
no one knows the in-between above what
happened in those relationships no one
knows but into any of those other people
but as far as I'm concerned Antonio
Brown has been nothing but outstanding
human being to me I posted the video cuz
I saw it on Antonio Brown story of him
saying goodbye to the murals in his
basement yeah going up to paintings of
Muhammad Ali and Kimbo Slice and Jerry
Rice and like saying goodbye and now
that I realized that you understand
motivation what was he doing with those
pictures on the wall like how did he
make himself better with those that's
what motivated him you know those those
those people people he looked up to and
has great work ethic and that was his
motivation in his weight room in his
house I mean to all of us we go this guy
is losing his mind but to you you're
like that's his tool yes that's a bee
man mmm that's a bee man yeah well you
thought a lot of the stuff written about
him was [ __ ] though I think there's
a stories out there that they were
little uh I definitely think he got into
a situation where it was him versed in
media yes and I think for a bee he likes
to control his own story that's why he's
very active on social media and I think
you know some people didn't like that
you know and he was dodging the media or
if you said something wrong to him and
he read it he wouldn't even interview
our quote and so I definitely people
took shots at them and the media can do
that so what's a trick that you have to
let these guys know that your place is a
safe space well the great part about it
is we don't do any marketing so every
single athlete we have is by word of
mouth
so obviously antonio gar
todd gurley tell say kwan Bartley hey
come train here right vice versa and on
and on and on and so it just becomes you
know a whisper throughout the different
leagues there's a train here and you
don't have to worry about XYZ and I had
mentioned this earlier what do you think
right now about the whole post my
offseason work out and show people I'm
grind
I mean I like it obviously you know
because I like seeing what guys are
doing but I think everything is a trend
and it's a fad and you know it's it's
again social media is just about
engagement so it gives fans a chance to
see these people outside of their
helmets are you know outside of the
basketball court or whatever so I think
it's cool what do you think about the
trainers that do it your competition I
mean that that's their thing I think
it's you know god bless them what you
gotta understand about me is I love all
trainers because I personally don't want
to Train everybody you know just the
guys that I have is more than enough
yeah and so you know if I have five or
six NFL guys five or six NBA guys I'm
happy there's still another 1,700 NFL
guys at 437 MBA guys yeah you know - so
you're almost at the point now where
you're kind of turning some people away
- I can't say turning people away but
just not having the time to deal with
them or give them the energy or effort
that they really need it seems funny to
me and new producer David shout out to
David ingmar he raised this question we
were thinking about interviewing you
about
it's like MBA coaches ordering around
somebody that makes like a hundred x or
20x of what you make and yet they're
down they're okay with it how and does
that ever feel weird to you - that like
Antonio Brown and Jimmy Butler and
you're like what the [ __ ] man
so no because again they they come to me
to get better and they come to me to
listen at the end of the day I think
they throw that money stuff out and I
forget how much money these guys really
have a really mate because it never has
brought up yeah you know and so I got
tell you funny story about just to give
you an idea of how competitive Jimmy
Butler is so a few years ago
we're playing the Sacramento Kings Jimmy
doesn't play that night so we go out go
to dinner and it a be facetimes me and
Jimmy's like I could beat him in a race
I'm like this guy serious they're
arguing back and forth I could beat you
in a race it could be to an array so
that summer was the first time they
train together and that's where they had
the cat
checking up the caching at UCLA with
Russell Wilson and stuff like that yeah
and Jimi in his mind really thought he
could beat Antonio Brown in a race and
really thought he could play receive an
NFL so those receiving videos you see
with him like I love you saw the one
with him and dak Prescott yeah he
serious he really thinks he can really
thinks he could play an NFL how do you
not tell him he can't I tell him all the
time all the time I don't mind him the
burden of bad news you know is his whole
nother level whole different body
movements who is the best type of
athlete overall what sports has the best
athlete that's tough to say because
basketball players have to be very agile
very fast and be able to jump very high
but an NFL defensive back think about it
you have to think about one person what
a person is doing while moving backwards
and then react to it how about just an
NFL if you were to rank position by
required like the best athletes you
think DB is the number one 100 percent
what's number two why receivers mmm okay
number three running backs really okay
just keep going defensive line I always
have defensive line higher than running
them what I find defensive lineman to be
the most impressive athletes possibly in
the world because I think that when we
see a guy like Quinn and Williams run a
40-yard dash a sub five 40-yard dash at
310 pounds at six foot five I go he
would do like if we were playing any
sport he'd be the most intimidating one
right I just I think that defensive
linemen are and they had the mentality
of a defensive back so they're super
cocky too right
I just love defensive lines I see that
yes am i what am i off about they're
nothing I mean you Quinton Williams is a
is a generational type athlete though
sure easy
I mean Fletcher Cox was like you're six
five three hundred pounds it's like
those special one right but then you
also have like the Aaron Donald although
Jesus stood so what does what is it how
you just wanna get your hands on Aaron
down a little bit I will that's the one
I lie between Aaron Donald he's a stud
so what I like to watch videos of him
I'm he's a stud I like I like what he
posted like what he does
he works hard I mean I like worse I
would a guy out in Pittsburgh I think so
strength coach for the University of
paid and he's he's instead I like
hearing down man so courts ODB's the
number and then word a quarterback's
fall in that ranking last you got to be
most mentally you know the most mentally
impressive but from fiscal standpoint
just on the ball who is the most
athletic quarterback in the NFL the most
athletic quarterback in the unity collar
Murray right now no we could curve that
the most athletic quarterback in NFL is
Lamar Jackson Lamar Jackson over us over
cam or Jackson over over who's the dude
at a some Hill Lamar Jackson Marv
Jackson stood man well what did you see
out of him he just uh he came on worked
out with this last summer just fast
agile tough thick he's good
I mean Russell Wilson's on a whole
nother level but as far as just sheer
athlete Lamar Jackson I haven't seen
enough of caller Murray yet yes you know
I mean I'm seen any of Commerce yeah I'm
gonna be honest but I'm rooting for him
are seem so quiet very quiet country
[ __ ] - how do you tap into him he's
motivated by his mother you know his mom
have a great relationship and he's the
hard-working tough kid you know so would
you like being his ear being like do
this for your mom when you find out
these motivators my mom how does that
change what you say to them I think it
sounds kind of creepy but he just size
me up again it looks like you are very
good at grocery shopping like you can
get through the aisles extremely fast
it's a great decision like pancake mix
I've seen a few videos where you'll have
sake one on a treadmill and Todd Gurley
yeah when you have two alphas how does
that change the atmosphere what's that
like competitiveness the the way they
compete is unbelievable and watching
Todd and say Kwan workout together it's
unbelievable you know cuz they push each
other they motivate each other just kind
of like to anything you could do I can
do better
type people and that's how it is we get
those two guys in a gym and I'm looking
forward to to this summer to create a
net magic again this year and is that
gonna be coming up this summer I mean
not when you do it June July can you
also so season ends for a lot of teams
in like January others that they're
lucky enough in February when do you
start getting involved everybody's
different
I mean Randall Cobb started he started
in January this year you know but todd
gurley started April 1st
it just it varies from when the players
whenever they're ready to get going you
know how beat up they got and you know
obviously running back is different you
have three gonna foreigner touches you
want some time off and then June though
is typically the big month so they get
they get a they get done with OTAs June
15th and then I tell guys who take two
weeks off and then we start that first
week of July and just hit it all the way
through training camp which is usually
like what August August 1st August 1st
so you got like one month one month how
much how much can you do in a month a
lot a lot a lot of transformation goes
on in that month at that time I'm trying
to get them ready to cut and be ready to
play football - high speed and high
tempo you know that's why you see having
bulky well everybody's different lot of
guys are coming off vacation so they
could have just put on a few pounds or
whatever but you know everybody's
different at that point who was there
ever an athlete that came back in
incredible shape and you were like wow
we're not even cutting or anything it's
just building on what you've already
done I think a lot of those guys I mean
say quantum Berkeley is probably the
most impressive athlete I've ever seen
in a long time since Reggie Bush Reggie
was a stud yeah let's take wanna sake
wants like 6 foot 230 shredded yeah
whose legs are crazy he's saying he's
agile I mean he's everything so that was
one of those things like even the first
day you were like wow when I first met
say Quan Barkley I was so amazed by how
focused and how serious he was so
immense a Kwan especially a person of
that stature you know like you know what
do you got to work on oh I need to you
know maybe my hands are you know this or
sake on what he have to work one
everything huh I'm gonna get better at
everything and in his mind it's like you
know you're already girl
and he wants to get better at everything
and the way he paid attention to detail
and the way he focused and how many
times a day he worked out I was like
this kids when this gives me a problem
how many times a day do you work out you
say qua work out two or three times a
day
Wow Turner summer that's got to fuel you
and you see a guy doing that
unbelievable
then you're just gonna pour yourself
into him there you go see now you hit on
the head when you see how bad people
want it and how bad they want to
sacrifice how bad they want to work you
do anything for them
how much can sake one leg press do you
think if I well people don't leg press
anymore it's like I'm sorry that's what
they do at your planet so squat yeah
squad I would probably say Oh probably
800 pounds for had to guess his legs are
ginormous to people like in like when
you guys are working out well people
talk about them not necessarily I think
a couple chicks walking by a few times
and mentioned his legs - hammy or he's
not big eyes so humble and so focused
he's not thinking about it you know I
think everybody around him too used to
it yeah yeah
so was there ever would you like if
Gurley and say corner working out
together would you say something to say
Quan in a weird way motivate Gurley 100%
Oh give me this person I would always
say you know say Kwan Todd is who you
were trying to be you know I always
always tell Todd hey se Kwang's coming
for your position mmm so it just
motivates them because it's the you know
those are our keys to the best backs in
the league and so you know I'd say that
they're they're definitely top five no
top - hold on please
Zeke is up there three I mean I'm not
gonna put David Johnson up there come on
we need to see it camara ya know I would
say the all-around guys it's probably
those two absolutely how is Todd doing
Todd's great you know it's funny because
Todd has Todd started April 1st and he's
worked so hard and he is so committed
and so dedicated in the the medical
staff over the earth of Rams are doing
such a great job with them and you know
I've been blessed to be a part of his
process and work with those guys to get
this to get Todd going and he's uh he's
looking good he's gonna play a little
lighter this year you
IMed about 218 219 and he was at one too
let's replay 224 225 sure you know but
not too much more lighter but uh man
he's he's so impressive everyday he
impressed me more and he's looking good
and I'm really excited to see what he's
gonna do this season were you always
talking to the Rams medical staff or
their training staff or was it because
of the Super Bowl of the injury and all
that stuff no I've always communicated
with them you know I've always
communicated with them when instead of
saying page with them because you know
I'm blessed to get a chance to work with
Todd outside of the training facility
and he does his thing but he's over
there every day working with the guys
there and it's a it's a lot of
communication that goes on but nothing
out of the ordinary can you share what's
like is it purse is it like inherently
personal what's going on cuz I just feel
like there's a lot of you both questions
yeah yeah I think so I think so too I
think ultimately Todd wants to win Todd
wanted to win bad I think just you know
the playoffs
those last two games there's the Super
Bowl game against the Patriots yeah the
game against the you know like all the
size I like like flexing it out and
stuff you know I just think just uh you
know he just didn't play how he wanted
to play and it just it just was one of
those things and I don't think that
there was an injury or anything that
that really stopped it is just his
number wasn't called and for whatever
reason it just he didn't have those good
games but people got understand in the
first round against the Cowboys he
played amazing under-filled yes yes
that's why it was so shocking yeah he
was we were all like this is Todd Gurley
top two running back in the NFL curry I
agree so I don't know if it's a
combination of just you know he didn't
get the certain plays or two carries I
really don't know because you never
talked about it because we never talked
about it because for me it was never an
issue it was just knowing the flow of
the game and knowing how things were
going as CJ was doing really well yes
didn't work out so I just was wondering
from your perspective because from the
outside
Iowa's going if this is a confidence
thing right how would you like is it
would you do you like sit down and have
a conversation be like are you good or
do you just start bacon and compliment
well no 1,000% you know me and Todd have
a relationship where we can be 100
percent transparent with each other and
at no point I may I was with him on
thing
given I was cut was constant touch
points there was no point where I felt
that there was any serious concern or
mentally Todd wasn't there yeah
so it was like Todd was always talked
and he hid we're reading all this [ __ ]
yeah
yeah it's crazy yeah same thing it's
gotta be funny to be on the inside and
see all that especially when you see the
kid every day you know and you know it's
it's tough you know I listen you know we
live in LA it was need talk radio and
everything or should we trade Todd
Gurley should we do this and do that I'm
psyched the kids fine you know and we
post some workout videos every now he's
fine
man it's the true thing is is we all
want todd gurley to be great because
that offense with him is special very
when Sean McVeigh can unleash the play
action by setting and plus when Todd
Gurley turns a corner oh yeah good
[ __ ] luck man that's the thing about
him that if everything is healthy him
and say Kwan I think even Gurley more
than say Kwan he's more of the home run
threat I feel like he's got that top-end
Georgia speed speed is through the roof
and I think that um I think the Rams got
a taste of the Super Bowl last year and
now be shutting on that if they're not
back this year hmm you know and I think
maybe kind of the stage was too big or
you know for what but they're gonna come
back coach McVeigh he's a sharp dude
he's a sharp dude but his body I mean
he's great he looks like he works out
cuz we face like only 32 or 30 30 like
probably four at this point but there's
a lot of 33 old coaches that don't look
like that yeah like the new coach the
bengals looks like in a like in a like a
secretary but you know that you know
Coach McVeigh was the Georgia State
player day year come in high school you
know he's a stud muffin me like the
triple option her he was the [ __ ] man
NFL players versus NBA players whoo what
are they like in the gym that's a great
question most NFL guys they've been
lifting waste their whole life and so
they're real rah-rah self motivating say
been doing it where I think sports
performance for the most part is just
kind of been really introduced to NBA
guys cuz you know back in the day
they'll be like I'm not gonna lift
weights cuz explain our ball yeah
exactly yeah and I think kind of you
know
Michael Jordan with with Tim Grover back
in the day then Kobe Bryant and you know
LeBron with his team and has kind of
really revolutionized how these athletes
should attack things in the offseason so
it's a lot more functional with the NBA
got more injury prevention except late
82 games and they travel a lot so to
make sure that they're limber their hips
are are flexible and make sure they have
all the tools they need to play 82 plus
game season it's more the focus for the
NBA guys I just also think too like
LeBron puts out a video of him on like a
medicine ball working on balance and I
have to imagine NBA guys are coming to
you and go and I want to do stuff like
that the funny part is they're not you
know uh you know LeBron is such a LeBron
has a phenomenal team his his trainer
Mike and Manly's has a phenomenal team
but you'd be shocked at how many guys
really try to copy other guys cuz Indy
what's different about NBA guys is NFL
guys will work out in groups like you
see say Quan and Todd yeah together let
NBA guys they want to work out
one-on-one they might bring in their
their their crew their friends but for
the most part they want to work out or
do you think that is I don't know that's
always been their thing the NBA guys
have always wanted to work out what on
giannis has said this to where he's like
you know a lot of people did you just
eat something yeah tell me what you just
put in your mouth chewing gums delicious
Oh Russian I thought it was like a
protein pill or something like I thought
like your phone protein no but Yanis had
a quote where he said everybody wants to
work out with me I don't want to work
out with that that's correct
I'm trying to beat all of them correct
where NFL you're saying it's more of
communal five guys let's push each other
yep my name is in whatever saying which
one do you like more um both because I
like the energy that the NFL guys bring
but I like that one-on-one personal
basis from the NBA especially if it's
like a Jimmy Butler where you know
you're gonna get like a thousand percent
yeah Jimmy's crazy man Jimmy doesn't one
no one in the weight room and easier
coolest group of NFL guys you've had I'm
gonna make you sweat that come on a
second I know oldest group
hope you enjoyed the flavor it's good I
had you know back in the day
I had TJ whose Masada Julian Edelman who
Danny Amendola Orlando Scandrick Terrell
Thomas Eric Wright Dashon Goldson they
were the nothing they're all fighting
for spots
yeah seventh-round pigs like super
scrappy guy and then you're mixing in a
Scandrick who's like one of the best
[ __ ] talkers there you go Edelman to
[ __ ] talk yes he is what year do you
remember anything from that like just
funny money was so added every day they
would go at it was almost like the wide
receivers first dbe's and they would go
at it every day being you have TJ who's
Masada who would just talk so much
Madison you said guys who they make me a
better trainer
because they questioned everything I did
they start to mess with me every day you
know what I mean and so it was a great
group a lot of energy super funny a lot
of trash-talking just uh you know some
interesting days can I ask you a tougher
topic yeah this just happened with
Patrick Peterson yeah peds and stuff
right and for me it's like it's an
emotional time like I get emotional
because I go it's such a cloud that
hangs over somebody's career right
especially a guy like Pat who like has
always been physically gifted yeah and
has always been special yeah and we've
never had to ask this question yeah and
it happened to Julian - yeah and and as
somebody who I'm sure like you keep it
pure and clean and all that it's kind of
hit you even harder than to hit somebody
like me right but you know what's funny
I never personally have seen people take
anything or anything crazy what I think
what happens a lot of times these guys
they'll take a supplement not knowing
that is been banned so when they say
that and then everybody goes yeah right
you're gonna know there's a good chance
it's happened 100% 100% because because
remember those banned substance list
Akasa getting updated so if we got
updated in March and in February you're
taking something you know that was
banned there you go but then this is the
like the if somebody gets arrested at 3
a.m. drunk driving
normal fans go you're wealthy enough you
should have a driver with this
conversation it's you don't know what's
going in your body or you don't have a
new
Trish inist that's staying up to it like
I think fans are always shocked by the
ignorance of how did you not know right
right I think if people go to a simple
supplement store and they see the
certification that's supposed to have
one there the NFL or the NFA whatever
they get it in boom just like that but
like you're not are you telling your
guys to take certain [ __ ] like do you
tell them what to take get very honest I
tell guys take two things protein and
fish oil that's it there is no gray area
with that yes'm
that's all fish oil for for joint
lubrication and protein just help their
muscles recover after workout and that's
it there's nothing gray about those two
items have you seen someone come with
just like a crapload of supplements yeah
I seen a lot of guys like take you know
different pills and different vitamins
different they've been recommended but
it's just kind of the nature that beefs
important what do you tell them tell
them whatever you know because my
biggest thing is to make sure that it's
all checked out so they go you check all
this stuff out you cleared past year
have you cleared it past your team
nutritionists cuz you don't have that
layer you said I'm saying forget what
your trainer says your agent says have
you ran this past your team nutritionist
because he's the one that definitely
should know there you go and why and
they just what forget or they go this
will be fine and it's different things
and different reasons for every guy
every guy is a different story I don't I
mean these guys have not cheated and
they're our entire lives
and to get that like hung on there on
their name is like it's a legacy
defining Pro and Patrick Peterson is
when the hardest-working physically
gifted athletes ever I think
whatever happen when him was just a pure
mistake mmm but I don't know Patrick
Peterson I root for him because at LSU
guys yeah I don't see him just going out
purposely taking something that he knows
is one of the mess of his career that's
what huh then everybody comes out and
speaks on their character and we all
want it to be true and it's like yeah
but you Fitz man it's tough it's tough
there's tough I just was wondering too
cuz we've always said this poor man if
you work out and you have good protein
and then you have a good diet like
you're gonna be fine I'll be fine
what are you gonna do increase it by
like a half an inch more like exactly
but so you know I just don't see the
benefit in all that [ __ ] I do not either
so 33 percent though they should be
doing fish oil too
let's go fish oil and protein and if
anybody wants to hit me up or posting
pictures to them to tag me anything yeah
I'll know but they wanted our answer the
questions I hope about what everything
you need fish oil though yeah awesome
you know multivitamin to multi fine what
kind of multivitamin do you take just a
man's multivitamin
yeah like centrum or something like that
I got like a GNC just I'm a basic I'm a
very basic guy yes yeah well the people
that I meet that are super into like the
training world are the ones that don't
take a lot of stuff yeah it's the
trainer at that Globo gym yeah
that's telling me that I need like a
pre-workout I took pre-workout one time
I was like I'm going to destroy everyone
in this gym yeah and then I crashed so
hard there's nuts yeah I was like who
puts this in your body like you're gonna
die your heart my heart's being a
million miles an hour likely for what
I'm self-motivated I wake up every day
at 4:00 a.m. and stop yeah every day man
Monday through Sunday no days off never
been on vacation they're taking a day
off going on vacation and how long never
my wife never my life bro we need to get
you to like Philly no no what I'm saying
is is you could do one of those like
beach workout videos yeah like Bali no
Tom Brady now you're making me into no
don't set you know why does that upset
you not that guy you know I'm just so
does that mean you don't like those guys
no I mean if that's their thing that's
their thing you know but come on let's
go to this island it will work out for
seven days we'll put cones on the same
like some woes that uh like some fire
fest type stuff yeah no that's not me
wow so you're you just like sweaty gyms
yep what's your favorite exercise lunges
there's a worse yeah that's are the most
effective very effective because
remember athletes
I know it's my problem I know my ownage
great for athletes you know because
walking lunges simulates the power that
they put out when they're running and
doing different exercises that's a thing
you think to like bodyweight lunges are
gonna be easy and then like you're on
your 20th one you're like all I'm doing
is squatting this sucks yeah you know
what I'm doing
did you have competition I don't know
shout out to all the trainers though I
love them how do you motivate yourself
cuz I'm sure there are you're telling me
there's not a single day you wake up
you're like I just want to hit the
snooze
oh all the time all the time and I mean
I have two kids yeah you know two and a
half year old and a 16 year old Wow
and so there's a lot of times where the
funny part about it is I'm a normal
person you know I go through issues with
my family and my kids make me mad and my
sister makes me mad and all this stuff
happens but the second I walk in that
gym all my problems go out the door
because I'm not walking in with somebody
who has you know their baby mama drama
and they have contractors coming exactly
and so I need to give all my energy to
them hmm have you ever been offered by
an NFL team to exclusively work with
them yeah yeah how many times does that
happen times happened this offseason
really yeah and what's the pitch usually
sound like nothing that I want there's
only one NFL team that I work for and
that's the New Orleans Saints because
it's home because it's all I want to
bring a championship to Bourbon Street
but my thing is I really want to I want
to work I want to work in on the college
level you know I work on the college
level really yeah like I see that dude
in Alabama
Scott Cochran that's my guy came from
LSU man I mean he is like he's crazy
he's definitely one of these celebrities
in your world oh yeah he's a love it
though cuz he's and he's it's all
authentic that he's not a fraud you know
it's all authentic so I love I'll follow
him when his coach Cochran is crazy
yeah yeah he's with my favorite guys and
so you like college why cuz you can
impact more people there you go can
impact more people have a bigger a
bigger influence because you know it's
tough in the NFL on the NBA at that
level guys have their own guys you have
their own resources and you know they're
doing their own thing so in college kids
have to listen to you or you could
punish them make a do stuff so you kind
of got a little more leverage over them
you're a great athlete so I would
probably work with like a college
basketball program or something like
that you know but you like the
independence right now no I would I mean
it's cool but remember there I had no
plan for this all this
happened I didn't like Sydney on open
business playing with you I'm gonna turn
you Todd girl you say yeah it is all
kind of happening I think naturally I
would prefer to say you can be gotten
right now oh yeah so if the saints hear
this or if like a polish basketball
program in a second in a heartbeat even
what do you feel in school school I
couldn't go back to West Virginia oh
right so when you hear how the Saints
and pelicans share an athletic staff
dream situation yeah but at the same
point my reaction was MBA and NFL
players trained differently is as
pregnant all the MBA players were
getting hurt yeah and so my first
thought is training staff yeah like it's
not it's not specialized am I was I on
the right track there no you're right if
it is barding the the Phoenix Suns
training staff which is very good yeah
I'm gonna injury prevention so hopefully
they get together because hopefully the
pelicans get Zion and we bring a
championship to Bourbon Street okay so I
wasn't crazy that could have been an
issue there absolutely absolutely
we had Collette CEO semele on and he was
saying that the Raiders last year he had
like a planet fitness guy yeah I can't
speak on that but why can't you speak on
that well I'll tell you what he said so
that you don't have to say anything he
just said that like he said we would go
to the the veterans and go pro like this
is not good and then they would go to
Gruden and he'd be like listen just
stick with it for a little bit and he's
been fired
since correct I just don't know how
somebody like gets that position what
what was he doing was he like you know
was Adam Adam it's funny when you see
what some of these guys do and you
wonder why teams have injuries you
wonder how people got those positions
but even more you now look at the
general manager or the head coach do
they really care because if you can keep
your athletes healthy that's to be your
most important theme you're giving guys
15 20 million hours a year and on top of
that from a look at the pelicans like
I'm a pelicans fan like when Anthony
Davis did hurt you know was gonna games
no yet I mean so you should think about
investing a lot of resources into
keeping those players helps so when you
hear that do you worry about all the
other athletes in that organism
solutely absolutely but one thing I've
never done is I always try to work with
teams I don't never want to bad-mouth
teams right but obviously you know if if
there's a common denominator and there's
a ton of injury some stuff you just
can't prevent but if there's just
countless soft tissue injuries yes like
that you got to take a look at four
people okay so what I like to do is give
the listeners little perspective that
they can pay attention to things that
will explain things later right what are
injuries that if they happen often to a
football team that the fans will go
something's wrong with the training
staff right now our players just aren't
injury prone growing in hamstrings groin
and hamstring us so if there's a team
like in OTAs where there's a lot of
groin and hamstrings what-what can I
point to strength coach and what are
they not doing they're not developing
there those muscles they need to develop
because if there's those issues that
means that their glutes aren't firing or
there's different issues that's going on
so there's not a proper warm-up or that
it's not being trained properly and
those are the two areas that you train
the most extensively because that's the
muscle groups that are being used to
mostly crowing and hamstrings lateral
change in direction explosion and
football such an explosion sport you
know what I mean stop and go and stop
and goes basketball though yeah I just
feel like they're also running the whole
court yeah but they I mean jumping up
for a dunk and all that so groin and
hamstrings look at ACLs and stuff that's
yes yes and no you know yes and no
sometimes you just can't prevent it but
for the most part that also means that
the calf muscles and the quad muscles
aren't strong
so there's pull nerves give there should
NFL players be playing on field turf
yeah okay yeah that was a big thing for
us for a long time I mean that's not
turf yeah natural grass is way back got
give yeah it's just when I see an NFL
player
their bodies are unlike any other humans
right and when they put a foot in the
ground if there's no give I mean then
that whole leg could be shot yes sir
that's just what gets me scared about
field turf even because I'm looking out
for these players too right
[Music]
just have you you said you'd
communicated with the Rams right how
often do you communicate with the team
has a team as a team ever reached out to
you and been like what do you do it like
do they get nervous all the time well
I'm mostly nervous but you know
fortunately I've worked with players
from every single team and most strength
coach have heard of me so they're there
most the times I mean all the time I
never had any problems when they might
not being cool and so I just encourage
communication so the strength coach
knows what we're working on what we're
doing so when your guy comes back you
know what to expect in vice versa hey
b12 Berkley anything what's your weight
goals for them and right he's like that
like I'm not a guy I'm at war with teams
I want to work with the teams and so do
you contact them or they contact vice
versa it just just depends yeah yeah
because that's that the thing is they
can't be counterproductive no no I mean
you can't you can't be counterproductive
as well either what's it the difference
between training and incoming rookie
like Anna Kiel Harry yeah or an NFL
veteran who's kind of been through it a
ton I'm glad you brought that up I have
said every year since 2014 that I don't
want to train NFL rookies anymore
because when you throw in the pressure
of the NFL Combine which is a high
stressful high-pressure situation and
their whole livelihood is only based on
running the 40 and how they and how they
how they perform at those drills you
look at for the first time in their life
they're really having money you look at
all these mock drafts and rankings and
people's stock is going up and down I
didn't play the game and so dealing with
the NFL rookie is tough with that being
said training to kill Harry this
offseason was probably the most
rewarding thing ever being with him on
draft night was probably the most
rewarding thing ever
because you talk about a kid who
sacrificed everything and went to have
had a very rough life and tough life and
came over here and was young and will
live with his grandmother and at times
they couldn't make it he live with his
friends and just a great human being and
just worked unbelievably hard grinder
grinder and to see him to get drafted
by God's favorite quarterback and he's
probably going to win the NFL Rookie of
the Year she's in a great situation it's
great to see so you were there wouldn't
kill Harry got Trapster
it was there even an ocean in the room
that it could be Patriots at 32 the
funny part about it is his agent picked
out a house we were like in I don't
think we were in Arizona we were like an
hour outside the city there was no cell
phones reception and so the teams were
calling but it's like the the calls kept
dropping so it was the idea it took like
five six seven eight a ton of calls to
finally he couldn't move and Belichick
went up and got him so it was it was a
great feeling a great situation
what made training to kill Harry so made
what made you so confident that he will
be a success in the NFL how focused he
is he's almost he's almost oblivious to
what's going on outside around him he's
just focused on training and playing for
sounds like the perfect Patriot yeah oh
yeah absolutely he would be fine I mean
knowing to kill him he would be fine
he's you know he's never been in trouble
he doesn't go out he doesn't do stuff he
doesn't he does everything the right way
he's him at Andrew Luck are probably the
to my two most favorite NFL pre-draft
guys ever and athletically with Nikhil
yeah I always thought the last few years
the Patriots relied on Gronk as their
5050 guy and then for half the season
last year Josh Gordon where Edelman is
gonna run the offense I mean know let's
go around the offense but those are your
ones in trouble throw it up there they
can make a play so what does Tom Brady
have and to kill Harry he has an athlete
that's going to compete and even he has
an athlete that he can go up and he can
get it and he's a lot faster than people
think I mean he returned kickoffs and
punts this year he wasn't just a
receiver and so again I definitely think
he's going to be a thousand receivers of
Rocky I definitely think he's gonna
probably win in a fellow rookie of the
year and I'm not saying that because I
trained him I'm saying because he's in
the best position of all offensive
rookies you know in the NFL this year
sure obviously caller Maurice had the
ball in his hands every you know every
play but I don't know how that's gonna
pan out when did you train Andrew Luck
2012 draft NFL Draft all right so take
me to young baby nerdy and your luck he
walks in the first day man first of all
probably the funniest guy Andrew Luck is
nothing how people think he is uh oh
he's cool he's a guy he's great
yeah the cell phone thing is true he has
a flip phone he's had since he was I
think in the eighth grade he's from
Texas
I'm in the first day he walked in man
came in with with blue dungaree jeans on
and it's just a sweatshirt like let's go
hey travel story to me actually heard a
lot of good things really excited to get
it going yeah absolutely I said you man
and he worked hard man I know if you
were his combine he was as big as as Cam
Newton and ran as fast he jumped
10 plus in the in the luck as he stood
he said I won Sabre in a 45 or low for
six of his last year at Stanford some of
the throat remember his pro day you're
like 80 yards or something like that
Andrew bloody luck is a stud he is a
stud you know he's another one of those
super focused guys very focused there's
there ever a time where you got under
Andrews skin never okay the only thing
that Andrew didn't like I mean that
you're he he didn't want any media
around so he did no media stuff I think
we agreed to do one thing with like one
of the publications and he was just
pissed
cuz that's such a balance yeah you kind
of need to show off who you're working
with but you don't want to upset them
and because you don't want it to seem
like they're you're using them correct
how do you do that balance again I think
mostly with me
I let the athletes bring in their film
guys or say hey let's film this or let's
do that but that's how I do it you know
for the most part I just don't post up
without their permission or without
knowing that I'm gonna post it our sneak
stuff out and it also makes sure that
they're comfortable so I mean I've
worked with a lot of guys I've never
posted before just because I didn't know
where they were at or what the situation
how many professional athletes now have
their own video crews almost every guy
at least every star player has her own
videographer is this a new thing that's
company yeah years yeah so when did it
start who was like the first guy to roll
in with a videographer first guy that
ever been was Antonio Brown and this is
probably three four years ago he rolled
in with the video guy and like you tell
me you have a guy yes my god are you
worried about it's that casual win and
they just start putting out clips now
clips as we were training he was like
hey post this
better put this on my snap but so my
Instagram but so my Facebook and at
first for you against it or for it
because for me to bother me with Antonio
because he was working the whole time so
it would literally be like you know
he'll do a set as she's walking back a
post at ya you know and and then now
it's like everybody almost everybody
yeah
is it a little ridiculous or do you it's
good I think it's great you know because
these guys now they're so focused on
their brand so from a branding and
marketing standpoint it's what they want
to portray so if you got to invest a
little money to get content out there to
get some marketing dollars you get some
other opportunities come on for it
strongest athlete you've trained
strongest athlete I've ever trained on
the I'll go through sport by sport ok
NFL side would probably be Jarrell Casey
OH
Terrell Casey expensive tackle Tennessee
Titan strong strong strong strong most
explosive that well it's the strongest
thing you'll seen Charl Casey do Jarell
Casey are miles geared mouse gears miles
gears a stud what's the strongest thing
you've seen neither of them do I seem to
rail Casey rep out 405 for multiple reps
those four or five pounds well miles
everything miles I've seen him do you
know hit a boxing bag for you know hit
everything he's just a athlete he's just
an unbelievable athlete and he's so
focused and so driven
he's another super smart guy too
different dude man dinosaur mate you're
over there at Texas A&M he's a different
guy man
no like I I've met him and he's he rolls
around like a super young crew of kids
you do and they're all like free spirit
and they I'm high school yeah and their
conversations are like really good most
explosive athletes Reggie Bush Wow like
not even a question wish where'd you
push
Reggie Bush before was there anything
off the field that was like a moment I I
just love the moments in the gym where
I'm curious like was there a box jump or
was there something that you're like let
me put this in front of him that I don't
even know if he can do wow he is that
explosive yeah I think Reggie Bush
injure me
and I just remember them doing you know
Jeremy grant 60 inch and Jalen Brown 60
inch standing vertical box jumps
unbelievable just stand-in there who
jump up 60 inches
same thing would Reggie Bush there was
nothing that Reggie couldn't do when the
force he put in the ground when we were
doing cutting drills unbelievable I mean
this guy was running at full speed stop
on a dime
in change directions and like the ground
like peels up
what's uh what's an exercise ten years
ago that doesn't exist anymore for
football players I think in exercise ten
years ago was just a barbell bench you
know and I see very few people doing
that now because it's so big on
isometric single arm single arm
exercises that it cuz more so for court
holding positions and so you don't see a
lot of barbell bench anymore what about
like what are some extra so what what
should be tested at the combine that is
not that's a great question I think they
got it all covered with the you know the
bench shows your stamina and strength
with this the 40 shows you speed the
agility drills shows your change of
direction and then the jump so you're
supposed to be so everything's pretty
much covered for the most part is there
one though that you think is more
indicative of an athlete's explosion the
jumps broad and verticals and bludgeon
yep and you knows what a forty one inch
vertical yeah what's your vertical I
don't know I don't in my church need
game sometimes do you really yeah I get
up there a little bit so if you designed
the NFL Combine you be actually kind of
cool or is now that you've experienced
like the emotional stress what what
would you change about it I'm glad you
asked I'm having to be I would all be
regional because you're getting athletes
in Indianapolis waking them up really
early in the morning in cold weather
I'll have an LA combine and I'll have a
Midwest one in the East Coast one have
it region no and have them test on the
first day so so what happens is they're
so stressed out by being in the meeting
room meeting meet with the teams going
to the doctor's office all
these different type of tests and being
you work out I'm working on the first
day mmm then go through all the other
stuff is it fear are these kids like
working out with you but at the same
time just like circled that one weekend
and it's just it's like a looming over
them 100% because again what they do
there can make or break their lives
their whole winter okay look at greedy
Williams for example greedy Williams was
army probably a top three pick coming
into the whole process he slipped to the
second round it cost him twenty twenty
five million dollars but he round a43
what happened at the combine he ran a
four three but his other drills he just
wasn't good at him mmm-hmm he just
didn't phrase that he just didn't
perform well at them you know and greedy
Williams is LSU kid I'm rooting for him
yes just it's tough you know he's gonna
he's lost money he would never be able
to make up I know so what what do you
say to calm them down you can't you
can't you try everything building up to
the process just say hey you got to
relax you got to relax you got to relax
you try to put them in pressure
situations as much as you can there's
nothing you could do to simulate the
actual combine it's a game time there's
nothing you can do to simulate you know
shooting a free throw you know with the
crowd chanting are you know Von Miller
to this workout with this guy where I
remember it was something called like
the anarchy workout where he would be
hanging on poles Oh crazy Frank crazy
for emphasis so you know how it is and I
remember reading that the crazy Frank
would yell at him if you let go people
died and he would try and motivate them
by like he'd have to transfer weight
from one thing to the next and if he
dropped the weight that was him dropping
a child into like a canyon and try to
get into Vaughn's head like you can't
quit or else people will suffer Wow so
this so crazy Frank is known oh yeah who
the hell's crazy crazy Free People I
don't know because you know he doesn't
show his face that's what I mean
straighten that so in this world of
everybody trying to get notoriety you
know here's this trainer that don't even
look at my face but I'm crazy can't so
names crazy Frank nobody knows his last
name he goes by crazy Frank and when he
does interviews he does him with his
face covered harem quarter for anchors
and what have you heard about him he's
crazy but about his workouts they're
intense you know I've watched some of
them some of them you know again like my
whole thing is this I don't never think
any workouts bad or good if does your
subject matter adapt to and are they
getting better so clearly he trans von
Miller he trained some other guys they
go by him he trains Blake Griffin for a
while Wow so you know he likes to do
like the sand dunes by the Golden Gate
Bridge right all the sand dunes in the
woods I don't even think actually go
into an actual gym it's all that's me at
the parking or here there man yeah crazy
[ __ ] very I saw you were training DJ
reader yeah I think DJ reader is one of
the again I love defensive lineman the
unknown special talents in the league
everybody is talking about JJ Watt and I
want to go
the only reason JJ Watt had double-digit
sacks is because they were worried about
DJ reader last year right put like this
in the game they didn't double-team DJ
he sacked Tom Brady twice mmm so he's a
great man he's lost he lost what 227
pounds his offseason
he's got down to 325 she was up to 363
53 55 we show the whole rap yeah how's
he feeling great he's great he just
called me X he called me yesterday man
he decide to get back in the summer and
you know he's such a great kid and he
works so hard and I think him now
playing at 325 this year instead of
playing at 350 he's gonna get a whole
nother loss especially cuz it's not
there's there's not that many 325 guys
exactly and there's really not some 350
exactly so he it body looks completely
different right correcting he's gonna be
faster and leaner and more supposed to
even have more endurance so he could
just go and go and go I saw Devin
Funchess yeah
go to the Colts we boy Andrew Luck first
season was this your first time working
out with him no he was here with there's
a last number - gotcha yeah so what
should we expect out of Devin Funchess
but first of all he is hilarious I don't
know you ever talk to him no he's very
opinionated he's super Detroit he works
hard he really spends a lot of money in
his body and he works extremely hard I
think he'll be fine man right there net
system with Angela Tom Brady and LeBron
James yeah I feel like set the new tone
for
or longevity by investing in your body
correct and now you talk about
videographers wouldn't you say fun just
invest in his body what does he do he
has just different people he always
works out he always pays everybody and
he has different people he'll fly in and
fly out to maintenance his body he'll go
live in different places he comes to LA
trains with me when you say maintenance
are we talking like hyperbaric chambers
or we talk to everything specialized
stretching your eyes everything there
you go from yoga instructors physical
therapists foot doctors whatever it
takes he's loose enough to join yes yep
he seems so excessive but it also seems
like if you got the money man think
about it if you're making 12 million
dollars a year
what's $200,000 or $300,000 it's been a
year to invest in your body what's gonna
keep making you more money and as a tax
write-off and is it really helping
absolutely why is it a tax write-off
because it's it's benefiting you from
your job takes all job-related I need to
write off my cable bill for my job
that's not gonna happen
I watch television for my job I got a
point you know what I mean but okay so
who else is like leading the way in
terms of investing in their bodies
Antonio Brown really yeah Antonio Brown
he gets it in he has a trainer
everywhere he goes he has massage
therapist everywhere he goes physical
therapist everywhere he goes
body specialist area where he goes he's
do you think Antonio Brown has a cheat
day
I don't think so I've never seen him eat
backs he's a chef too
he's a chef that cooks all his meals
forms fish chicken and rice yeah and
then do you have cheat days yeah all the
time
okay what's your cheat day like po boys
man po boy yeah my cheat days are any
days I'm in New Orleans really you I
mean Chris Johnson CJ 2k yeah he was
another guy where I think as time goes
on we're gonna forget how explosive and
special he was absolutely absolutely
he's a guy definitely think he worked
hard man I definitely can keep peaked
before his time and if he would have
come around the pass catching running
back era he was right before absolutely
just missed it just don't think my guy
Ted Ginn is as fast as he thinks he is
well that's a great man you're in New
Orleans guy
I think I think there's so many fast
young players I think Ted Ginn still has
it but there's just so many young fast
players in the NFL and again tag in is
still probably a four three I think
there's a few for two guys who were they
he got John Ross for the Bengals you got
I think he also plays corner for the
Minnesota Vikings he's really fast ray
Wayne straight Wayne yep he got tree
Wayne's marques good what a super fans
Goodwin
yeah really fast I mean honestly I would
say Kwan Barkley in a race against you
those guys really yes sir yes sir
absolutely those legs bro unbelievable
do you only do athletes or do you also
have like a wealthy CEO that's like I
need to be pushed
oh well at our gym yes you know I
personally don't get a chance to work
with them cuz I'm so tied up with the
hell you sure but yeah we get a lot of
uh you know Freddie Gibbs and people
like that to come in there and train I
guess overall like as you look at the
NFL can you tell if a guys can have a
big season when he shows up and trains
with you or is or there are so many
factors in the NFL that it's really hard
there you go that's a great question
more so in the NBA side you can tell if
a player like I knew Seth Curry was
gonna be great this year because what he
kept one saying in the offseason my body
feels so good my body feels so good he's
having a breakout here in the NFL with
so many factors you know he have a
living guys on the side of a ball
coaching every and so you know if the
guys going to be physically ready to
perform but you can't control if they're
going to have a breakout year they're
gonna get the touches they need all
right snaps they need what's so
interesting too and Ted was here we were
talking about cam going vegan and Ted's
like cam is gonna have his best year
it's just this notion to the NFL has
gone from sighs to streamline correct it
feels like a seismic shift in the
mentality of the sport correct the same
thing in the NBA you know remember when
LeBron was really big and both yeah and
he came back lost the weight and that's
just what it is it's about being long
and limber now you wanna try and Zion
I'll let it ring holy [ __ ] can you
imagine I'll train him for free just
wrap it up like this we were talking
about motivation
was there anyone that you had that was
motivated very uniquely compared to
anyone else you've ever had I think
Jimmy Butler you know I think Jimmy
Butler is his whole he's that different
of a cat he's a different dude he's a
different dude but he's I think for
Jimmy
he was so doubted and counted out his
whole life and he's always being like I
won't go to NBA I'm gonna write and
again you know was never all League or
won anything in high school went to a
junior college went to Marquette play
like the four you know I mean and so he
always was kind of doubted and so now to
see where he's had to be a four-time
all-star max contract player he
constantly just funnels himself follows
himself talks himself up have you ever
had an athlete that just couldn't get
motivated and you're like this guy ain't
gonna make it now that I've ER trained
really well you refuse to train a guy
absolutely why waste my time because I'm
giving you the same passionate energy
every single day why if you don't want
to give me the same so you've had some
big-name guys that you were like now I'm
good no more so I've had guys that have
called me or approached me about
training them and I've acts a player
bottom line now you don't train it
really it happens a lot anyway you wanna
share no say okay so one thing that we
do need to work on is your Instagram I
know you don't want to share anything
but you heard the beat in the beginning
my guy rod Simba he has he sent me a
bunch of beats and I want to play one
for you that I am happy to give it to
you and that the next time you have a
really good workout video
Curly's in there and say Quan and you
put a little editing in there I'll give
you the song and you can use this and
I'll play for you this is rod Simba
see from Philly okay okay can you see
like curly stretch okay and now it's go
time
oh yeah oh yeah we work with this Oh
done done deal rod Simba
I got you I mailed him and I said dude I
appreciate all these songs what do I do
and he goes if you can get some of the
trainer's tuck it in dude right couldn't
you see like so this one like slide
inside on that [ __ ]
yeah they see me hits the Instagram will
make sure he tagged BTEC um I got you I
appreciate you man like you got any
questions for me yeah you're good you're
gonna call me out for my taste in women
again absolutely [ __ ] macaroni
hit up travell on social what are your
handles at travel games and athletic
games and at athletic games hit him up
check it out and then just kind of like
be attention now groins hamstrings
that's what we're paying attention to
appreciate you brother
likewise show yourself man all right so
thank you guys so much for listening to
the travell gains interview now I have a
freestyle for you dude slid into my DMS
and said I love the rod Simba beat dudes
name is Liam Cronin you can find him on
instagram at liam swag one and he said I
got a freestyle I'd do it over the beat
send me the file I'll send it back I
said okay I really enjoy it I'm gonna
play it for you the only thing I'm gonna
say is he has one line about Sims that I
don't fully endorse but I appreciate the
homie standing up for the homie so here
is Liam Cronin aka Liam swag 1
freestyling over rod Simba's beat the
33% y'all are the best now like Tyreke
at the track meet untold stories from
the side of the athlete like Howard
Cosell I would armor bro bring suit to
the public his services are thorough in
and microphone slimfast like comebacks
from Pat mahomes and weather crazy in
your car or riding on the subway flying
on a plane downloaded on the runway
don't pay attention to what phil simms
son say the story of the games more than
what you see on Sunday we up here coming
out of left go field and y'all know that
we ain't protecting the shield so punt
this [ __ ] as loud as you can is the Audi
SK Oh a man Liam Cronin Liam Cronin did
the damn thing
Liam Cronin did the damn thing and this
is the lef koe man appreciates you guys
so much
get up into travell Gaines's twitter
instagram shoot that guy some love you
could tell that he really cares about
this [ __ ] and we may have some big
things in the works LEF the k to the OE
you know how I be so slowly aren't I
gonna slow down y'all are great Rutzen
but keep making great music my friends
and to all the homies if you're doing
the 33 days eating like a homie let's go
[Music]